foreign
[Music]
I've been itching to do this explainer
for so long uh oh okay this is going to
be on the Bose Einstein condensate okay
okay and I bet you've been just itching
to know about that oh my God I can't
tell you how many sleepless nights I
have had thinking about the both kinds
Buzz Einstein condensate
I'm I'm actually building a particle
collider in my basement because it just
means that much to me
no anyway I don't even know what what is
the post well you've heard of Einstein
Bose was an Indian physicist oh and the
boson is a type of particle right that
is named in his honor and you might have
heard of the Higgs boson as a different
kind of boson so so
here's what's interesting with a Bose
Einstein condensate it's uh it's a it's
a subdivision of condensed matter
physics where matter gets very dense and
very close to itself and you can do that
by reducing the temperature so that the
particles don't vibrate as much okay and
as you make it colder and colder and
colder and colder all right now here's
what's going on yeah okay it needs a
sweater
and I have to whisper because it might
distort the particles okay
it's a beautiful day here at Augusta
answers the winds are slightly out of
the West as uh as the particles line up
on the 18th and we've we've got a by the
way something about sweaters if you're
the same temperature as the outside air
a sweater will do nothing
it hasn't it can't it can't warm you
wait if you oh my God yes you're right
yes right a sweater is not inherently
the sweater is just fabric that's an
insulator really correct so if you are
warmer than the outside and then you put
on a sweater it keeps your warmth in you
right but if you are the same
temperature right as you say you got you
got nothing your clothing won't do
anything by the way I do know and I hate
to say it and don't write I know a
couple women who will put on a sweater
when it's 98.6 degrees really what so
chilly in here from the top okay oh my
God it's so cold okay
yes the thermodynamics of men and women
yes have never been the same yeah you
know they did a study and they found
that women are actually colder no they
did a study and found out that the
temperatures in Office Buildings were
specked for men because it was at a time
when only men were occupying the office
buildings and so yeah the women end up
colder had they expected for women men
would be complaining how hot it was okay
you're right up you know that's why I'm
glad I'm a man
no I'm joking do not write that is not
that's called a joke that's it okay it's
not right because I don't okay that
would have rocked the house in 1987.
right you know let's get back so these
particles you're lowering the
temperature okay so in quantum physics
every particle is also a wave
okay holy Jesus give me a second man
give me a second Quantum fixes every
particle is also away now is that
because they're vibrating it's it's you
want to ask rational questions about a
reality that still transcends our Common
Sense okay gotcha um all right so what
you're saying here is like these are
things you have to accept by suspending
your natural understanding or your
understanding your limited understanding
limited understand brought to you by
your own five senses right on the planes
of the Serengeti to not be eaten by a
lion right all right the universe is
vastly more complex than that gotcha and
involves statements that on the face of
it seem
because your intuition is not Quantum
intuition right it's classical right
yeah that's what I mean by your natural
understanding that world around you okay
correct all right so now let's get back
to this every particle is a wave on the
quantum level okay correct all right and
so
on the quantum is also a wave and so you
have a jumble of particles and they're
they're all doing their thing you can
look at what wave is associated with and
what wavelength okay and they're each
doing their thing they're all
independent particles okay so let's cool
them down
as they vibrate less
they have less energy associated with
them and their wavelength grows aha
okay okay all right so just hang with me
now I want to lose you okay I'm with you
right now right now okay okay a
characteristic wave of the particle
as it slows down okay begins to grow
right
now there's a What's called the
Heisenberg uncertainty principle oh okay
right which is the more you know
about a particle's position
in Space the less you know about its
energy
and the more you know about its energy
the less you know about its position in
space
okay okay now there's a geeky way to get
out of a speeding ticket
um where the cop stops you and it says
do you know how fast you were going and
I and you just say no
um that means I'm everywhere or
sometimes it's some stupid Quantum okay
that's surely to get the black man shot
and then
there you go that's how that works
that's how that works all right so
anyhow so you have these particles and
as you cool this material when I say
cold I don't mean put it down in the
freezer yeah I'm talking on a like
Kelvin absolute temperature scale where
zero is the coldest we have a whole
explainer on that one yes we did I
remember yes you can get down to 10
degrees and nine eight seven six five
four three two one a half a degree a
tenth of a degree a thousandth of a
degree you just keep getting this colder
and colder and colder and the
wavelengths of each of these particles
gets longer and longer and you reach a
point
where all the wavelengths
overlap each other for every single
particle
and they become one
they've condensed they they've condensed
and become one functioning particle oh
okay they didn't just condense and
become a solid thing right all their
waves which used to be separate and
distinct
are now overlapping and resonating with
each other they're the Voltron of
particles okay I forgot who Voltron is
who's that that's the one where all the
little robots come together to make one
big challenge yes robot there it is
there it is what what what movie was
that what what comic book was that
Voltron oh Voltron is the story yeah
that's the story okay that is it yeah so
so all the particles come together and
they become one meta particle a
functioning metal Metapod correct
because they all resonate together at
the same time and this is this is why
you can't think of matter as only uh
particles or waves all right because
depending on the situation they will
function as one or the other and in some
cases both
and so oh yeah and by the way there's a
lot of phenomena that's so that's a Bose
Einstein condensate when it when it CR
it's it happens like quick as you drop
the temperature it transitions boom it's
basically a phase change in what it is
it's it's weird for us to think that but
is it really any weirder than having a
transparent liquid all of a sudden
become solid
right now think about it if you've never
been in a freezing temperature and
someone has a cube of ice a cube of ice
they say what's that it says water they
say no it's not because I can't drink it
and it's not a liquid and it's not right
[Applause]
[Laughter]
now why the only burn the witches and
not the warlocks do you know why why did
they never find the Warlock is the
question
so the men had all the power I guess
which I don't understand why every woman
the person who ever because it's always
a guy right you know you which and
immediately if I was the woman I'd have
been like yes I'm a witch he's my
warlock
yeah totally take that one out yeah
we're going we're going down together
fight the fire with fire fire
so other phenomena like this one of them
is called super fluidity you know what
that is the fluid becomes a superfluid
which means if you pass something
through it like your fist right there is
no resistance to your hand moving
through that volume
it just envelops your hand as though
nothing is there it's super fluidity
then you can have super conductivity
where the material offers no resistance
to the movement of electricity so you
don't lose any electric power to heat
okay
and it and you and you have perfect
transmission of electricity and so you
can have superconductivity and from that
you can get super conducting magnets
which are extremely powerful rotating
yeah yeah you get some of that you get
some of that okay well you get a maglev
train where that would help out it could
be totally happening if you can get
superconducting magnets to do that the
problem is you can't cool everything to
fractions of degrees above Kelvin any
sort of high temperature superconductors
high temperature which would still be
very cold and so it's a whole thing that
it's a whole Frontier in Material
Science and in physics wow so the point
is none of these phenomena make any
sense in a classical world right but
when you
um bring in Quantum forces and put it
under those conditions you need quantum
physics to understand it
and so I just I just think it's cool
that all these particles can condense
and act as one meta system and you said
it's not Ultron who was it did you say
oh Voltron Voltron is a sum of smaller
robots that's acting as a single robot
as a single robot yeah that's Voltron is
a Bose Einstein condensate look at that
that's pretty awesome yeah that's right
so there it is that's that's quick and
that was great
uh yeah I just we need a healthy respect
for quantum physics as we enter the
realm of quantum Computing where once
again we exploit the weird wacky stuff
that is normal in quantum physics and is
out of the out of our life experience
from our senses
and so
there it is Chuck yes okay that is super
duper fly no it's super duper conducting
ah
oh by the way speaking of super duper
yeah we're gonna build the world's
largest particle accelerator you know
how you accelerate particles okay you
get a particle with a charge in it and
then you shoot it into a a magnetic
field okay and if you vary that magnetic
field you can accelerate the particle
but the particle wants to have its
direction of motion changed it starts
arcing so you know exactly how much it's
going to Arc you make a tube that's
round and then you alter the magnetic
field in that tube to accelerate the
particle this is how every single
circular
particle accelerator works okay and you
can only accelerate particles that have
charges can't accelerate neutrons
because they don't have charge okay
that's that joke in the bar Neutron goes
walks into a bar said
um
uh Neutron works on the bar and says I
like a beer so here it is and the
neutron says how much and the bartender
says for you no charge
that's stupid stupid so just as we go
forward just embrace all that quantum
physics brings you and don't try to
question it yeah you can't yeah you
can't because you're questioning from a
foundation that is not the world in
which of laws that govern Quantum
phenomena so you just have to grow
accustomed to quantum physics that if
anyone says I understand it now no you
don't right no no it just is right it
just is that's great all right dude this
has been another explainer that was
amazing yeah weird wacky things on the
frontier of quantum physics wacky things
yes that was uh
uh Johnny Carson would say weird and
wacky thing you are correct sir
all right Chuck always good to have you
always a pleasure all right there's been
another Star Talk explainer keep looking
up
[Music]